you know my latest obsession
is this concept of finite and infinite
games and i've i've mentioned finite
mindedness or infinite mindedness a
couple times while we've been discussing
this goes uh back to the mid-1980s uh a
philosopher and theologian by the name
of dr james karst defined these two
types of games finite games and infinite
games a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football there's always a beginning
middle and an end
and if there's a winner that means there
have to be losers
then there are infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means new players can join
at any time
and sometimes you don't even know who
all the other players are
the
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
we are players in infinite games every
day of our lives whether we know it or
not nobody wins education for example
you know you can come in first for the
finite amount of time you're at school
when we agree upon the time frame the
school year and we agreed upon the
metric grades
but nobody wins education
uh um and likewise nobody wins business
there's no such thing as winning
business it doesn't exist right but when
we listen to the language of so many of
our leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't always know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one
being the best or beating their
competition
based on what
based on what agreed upon time frames
metrics and objectives and this is a
problem because when we play with a
finite mindset in an infinite game when
we play to win in a game that has no
finish line there are actually some very
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big one being the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation and the decline
of innovation and so we actually have to
adjust our mindset to fit the game that
we're playing and in the case of cyber
security you know you're you're actually
trying to prevent crime from happening
the criminals aren't trying to beat you
they're trying to do more they're just
trying to get more money
they're just trying to trick people they
just want access they actually don't
care about you and your cybersecurity
they're just trying to do more crime
right it's an infinite game
and you don't even know who all the
criminals are there's no such thing as
winning cyber security it doesn't exist
it's an ongoing cat and mouse game and
so you have to have the right mindset
for the game you're playing and in this
case it's not about winning it's about
constant improvement and it goes back to
that analogy that we discussed right at
the beginning when we talked about the
lifestyle of business versus trying to
treat it like a finite game right which
is it's not the end of the the financial
year doesn't symbolize the end of the
game
it's just a marker it's just a waypoint
and so all of these things that you and
i have been discussing is all about
constant improvement you'll never be
perfect at any of it ever that's not the
point the point is that you're
constantly working to advance and you're
constantly saying how can we be better
how can we better relative not only to
our to the other players in the game but
also relative to the criminals in the
game because
you could be the best quote unquote uh
compared to all of all of your uh of the
other companies in the marketplace but
if the criminals are smarter than you
then then there's no point
um so so i think that's that's to adjust
our mindset to play for the game we're
in which is the game of business and
especially cyber security which really
is an infinite game
i think is really really important